WHEN...
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
OKAY, I WAS JUST SAYING TO
HANNITY, IF YOU OR ANYONE YOU
LOVE IS THINKING OF APPLYING TO
LAW SCHOOL, YOU MUST BE HAVING
MAJOR SECOND THOUGHTS TODAY.
THREE PROFESSORS PRATTLED ON
ABOUT HOW TRUMP MUST BE
IMPEACHED 11 MONTHS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
THEIR DELIVERY WAS ALTERNATIVELY
ANGRY, DISMISSIVE, AND TEDIOUS.
DESPITE THE WALL-TO-WALL
COVERAGE AND RELENTLESS HEIGHT
BY THE DEMOCRATS, TODAY'S
SOPORIFIC SYMPOSIUM CRATERED ANY
HOPE THAT THEY ARE GOING TO COAX
AMERICANS INTO SUPPORTING
IMPEACHMENT.
HERE ARE THE TOP FIVE REASONS
YOU KNOW IT'S OVER.
FIRST, TODAY'S LEGAL EXPERTS
TRIED TO PASS OFF AS FACT FLIMSY
THEORIES AND UNSUPPORTED
INFERENCES, AND THEY USE THOSE
THEORIES AND INFERENCES TO
CONCLUDE THAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BASICALLY BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
SPEAK OF THE PHONE CALL ITSELF
OF JULY 25TH IS EXTRAORDINARILY
CLEAN TO MY MIND, IN THAT WE
HEAR THE PRESIDENT ASKING FOR
A FAVOR THAT IS CLEARLY A
PERSONAL BENEFIT, RATHER THAN
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE INTEREST
OF THE NATION.
>> ACTING ON HIS OWN PERSONAL
BENEFIT AND NOT FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE COUNTRY.
>> HE INVITED THE RUSSIANS, ARE
LONGTIME ADVERSARIES COME INTO
THE PROCESS THE LAST TIME AROUND
BECAUSE HE HAS INVITED THE
UKRAINIANS INTO THE PROCESS AND
BECAUSE HE SUGGESTED HE WOULD
LIKE THE CHINESE TO COME INTO
THE PROCESS.
>> Laura: INTO THE PROCESS.
STANFORD LAW GRADS SHOULD DEMAND
REFUNDS FOR ANY CLASS TAUGHT BY
KARLAN.
AN EQUALLY PLAUSIBLE MOTIVE
COULD BE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS EVERY RIGHT TO KNOW WHETHER
UKRAINE MEDDLED IN THE LAST
ELECTION, AND IT'S FOR THAT
THEORY THAT THE PRESIDENT
SOMEHOW WAS TRYING TO PERSONALLY
BENEFIT FROM HIS DEALINGS WITH
ZELENSKY.
JOE BIDEN WASN'T AND STILL IS
INTO TRUMP'S POLITICAL OPPONENT
IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
HE IS ONE OF SEVERAL.
SO HOW CAN THEY SO DEFINITIVELY
CLAIMED THAT THIS IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S GUIDING, SOLE
MOTIVATION?
ANSWER, THEY CANNOT.
SECOND, YOU KNOW IT'S OVER WHEN
3 OUT OF 4 LEGAL EAGLES WERE
TRUMP-HATING PARTISANS.
BASICALLY ELIZABETH WARREN GAVE
$1,000 TO HER LAST SUMMER AND
TRUMP'S RAPID RESPONSE BROUGHT
THIS UP WHEN SHE ADMITTED SHE
WAS TRIGGERED BY THE MERE SIGHT
OF THE TRUMP HOTEL BUILDING IN
WASHINGTON.
>> I GOT OFF THE BUS AND I
WALKED UP TO THE HOTEL AND AS I
WAS WALKING PAST WHAT USED TO BE
THE OLD BUS OFFICE BUILDING AND
IS NOW THE TRUMP HOTEL, WHICH, I
HAD TO CROSS THE STREET OF
COURSE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ARE YOU JUST SAYING THAT?
>> GOD NO.
>> Laura: TRIGGERED, AS SHE
WAS IN THE OBAMA DOJ AS WELL.
FROM UNC LAW SCHOOL, HE WANTS
MEDIA EFFORTS FOR AL GORE.
HE ALSO WORKED FOR THE
BILL CLINTON PRESIDENTIAL
TRANSITION TEAM IN THE 1990s.
A PROFESSOR AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL HAS BEEN ARGUING FOR
IMPEACHING TRUMP FOR YEARS.
HE EVEN ONCE SPECULATED THAT
TRUMP COULD BE IMPEACHED OVER A
TWEET THAT HE SENT CLAIMING
OBAMA HAD WIRETAPPED HIS
CAMPAIGN.
BUT BEYOND THEIR BIAS, THERE WAS
A NASTY, BITTER UNDERCURRENT
THAT BUBBLED TO THE SURFACE
AGAIN FROM PROFESSOR KARLAN.
>> WHILE THE PRESIDENT CAN NAME
HIS SON BARON, HE CAN'T MAKE HIM
A BARREN.
>> Laura: SHE LATER APOLOGIZED
BUT STILL COULDN'T RESIST TAKING
A JAB IN HER APOLOGY AT THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW, CONTRAST THOSE PARTISANS
WITH THE G.O.P. WITNESS.
PROFESSOR JONATHAN TURLEY.
HE IS NOT A TRUMP SUPPORTER, HE
VOTED FOR CLINTON AND OBAMA.
BUT THAT MADE HIS METHODICAL
TAKEDOWN OF THE IMPEACHMENT SHAM
ALL THE MORE CONVINCING.
SPEAK OF THE RECORD DOES NOT
ESTABLISH OBSTRUCTION IN THIS
CASE.
IF YOU ACCEPT ALL OF THEIR
PRESUMPTIONS, IT WOULD BE
OBSTRUCTION.
TO IMPEACH A PRESIDENT ON THIS
RECORD WOULD EXPOSE EVERY FUTURE
PRESIDENT TO THE SAME TYPE OF
IMPEACHMENT.
IF YOU MAKE A HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR OUT OF GOING TO THE
COURTS, IT IS AN ABUSE OF POWER.
IT'S YOUR ABUSE OF POWER.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW IT'S OVER
WHEN EVEN THE DEMOCRATS' PRESS
ARE ADMITTING THIS THING IS A
HARD SELL.
>> THE NOTION OF HAVING FOUR
ACADEMICS IN THE BROADER GOAL
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE TO PULL THE
PUBLIC ALONG ON THE IDEA OF
IMPEACHMENT, THAT CAN'T BE
CHANGING.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW IT'S OVER
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS WERE HOPING
TO INVOKE THE FOUNDERS.
>> THE FOUNDING FATHER SAID,
SHALL ANY MAN BE ABOVE JUSTICE
AND ALEXANDER HAMILTON RODE THAT
HIGH CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS
MEAN THE ABUSE OR VIOLATION OF
SOME PUBLIC TRUST.
>> JOHN ADAMS ONCE RODE TO
THOMAS JEFFERSON.
>> JAMES MADISON SAID THAT
IMPEACHMENT WAS NEEDED.
>> HE GOT A WHOLE MUSICAL AND WE
ARE JUST GOING TO GET THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
>> Laura: ARE YOU JUST
DEVASTATED THAT OBAMA DIDN'T PUT
HER ON THE SUPREME COURT?
YOU'VE HEARD OF SCHOOL OF ROCK,
RIGHT?
WILL THEY WERE STARTING IN LAW
SCHOOL OF ROCK.
>> I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THEY WOULD THINK.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO MAKE A
CASE TO GEORGE WASHINGTON THAT
YOU COULD IMPEACH OVER A
CONVERSATION HE HAD WITH ANOTHER
HEAD OF STATE, I EXPECT HIS
POWDERED HAIR WOULD CATCH ON
FIRE.
IT'S A FORM OF NECROMANCY THAT
ACADEMICS DO ALL THE TIME.
>> Laura: NICE USE OF THE WORD
NECROMANCY.
YOU KNOW IT'S OVER WHEN
DEMOCRATS, AFTER ALL OF THEIR
OUTLANDISH CLAIMS, STILL WON'T
SAY HOW OR EVEN IF THEY WILL
VOTE.
>> I'M GOING TO RESERVE ANY KIND
OF MODE OF PUBLIC JUDGMENT.
>> I'M GOING TO RESERVE
JUDGMENT.
>> NO DECISION HAS BEEN MADE AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE GO FORWARD
WITH IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: MAYBE THEY ARE
LYING, I DON'T KNOW.
BUT A BETTER EXPLANATION IS THAT
THEY WANT TO GIVE THEMSELVES AN
OUTCOME OR PERHAPS SOME WIGGLE
ROOM.
GOT TO SEE WHAT THOSE LATEST
POLLS ARE LOOKING LIKE.
THEY SAY THE FOUNDERS BUT WHAT
THEY ARE REALLY RELYING ON IS
FOCUS GROUPS.
THIS THING HAS GONE SOUTH AND
THEY ALL KNOW IT.
BUT THIS HAS BEEN A GREAT
24 HOURS FOR TRUMP AND YESTERDAY
HE WAS DOMINATING AGENDA OVER AT
THE NATO SUMMIT, PUSHING FOR
MORE MEMBER DONATIONS TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
WE ALL LOVE THAT.
LAST NIGHT HE WAS MOCKED BY
FOREIGN ELITES IN LONDON.
TODAY HE WAS MOCKED BY ACADEMIC
ELITES ON CAPITOL HILL.
CHALK UP ANOTHER WIN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.